Currently, the app shows dummy data
that was hard-coded into the XML file.
Let's make the actual
weather data appear on screen
using the Forecast Adapter.
For now we'll use the same layout for
all list items.
But we'll incorporate the today.xml
layout in the next video.
Conceptually the forecast adapter
manages the logic so that for
each row in the cursor we create
a corresponding list item.
Think back on the explanation in
lesson one about the array adapter.
Except instead of the data
source being an array,
now the data source is
a cursor from the database.
The layout for the list item is defined
in the list item forecast xml file.
For one row of the cursor we're going to
go through and extract out the values.
We call it binding
the data to the views,
because we take the value in each
column and set it in a different view.
For example the high temperature value
would be set onto the high
temperature text view.
The low temperature value will be set
on to the low temperature text view.
For the next row we bind
the data in the same way.
Until we create a list item for
each row in the cursor.
Currently our code
defines forecast adapter
as extending from
the cursor adapter class.
If you look at the documentation for
cursor adapter, you'll notice
that it is an abstract class.
There are two abstract methods
that we need to override.
Bind view, and new view.
The new view method, returns a new list
side and layout that has no data in it.
The bind view method,
takes an existing list item lay out, and
updates it with the data
from the cursor.
In the forecast adapter class
in the new view method,
we inflate the list_item_forecast
XML layout.
Then in the bindView method we
bind the data from the cursor to
the individual views.
For example, from the cursor we
read out the weather description.
Then we have to go through the view
hierarchy to find the text view
that has the id,
list_item_forecast_textview.
Once we find the text, once we,
once we find the text view then we can
update it with the right description.
We've provided a gist below of the
bindView method to get you started, but
we left some to do's for you to handle.
We've provided a gist of code for the
BindView method to help you get started,
but we left some to do's in there for
you to do.
In the gist, we also included some
helper methods and strings for
date formatting.
That's because in our
current implementation,
all the dates are displayed
in the same way.
In the wire frames through,
we have a more friendly date format.
Such as today, tomorrow, Wednesday,
Thursday, etcetera here's the logic for
what the helper method does to
get the friendly date's string
if it's this week it says today or
tomorrow or the day of the week.
If it's more than a week out then we use
the format Monday, June 8th and so on.
After you compile and run the app,
the actual weather forecast data
should now be showing in the app, and
it's using a more friendly date format.
Check these boxes when you're done.